he fans to commemorate Dwayne Wade's
final regular season home game we've
created a life-size number three
containing giant versions of the way
pins which were created to celebrate the
biggest moments in Dwayne's career
[Applause]
and now he fans direct your attention to
heat TV and every story act 3 is the
most important chapter the Miami Heat
are on the clock with the fifth pick in
the 2003 NBA Draft the Miami Heat
select Dwyane Wade from Marquette
University it delivers the stories
resolution the heroes triumphant return
home to claim what is his if I can do it
all over again our low to go five and
once again to Miami because it's a place
where I feel I belong in other words act
3 is where that hero becomes a legend
[Music]
by the master of across the plane ways
new nickname is flesh because I think
he's the fastest Guardian bit one of
your story you took the lead by storm
[Applause]
believable may have begun as the Windy
City's native son but you soon became
the Magic City Savior the one who
brought us from the brink to capture the
team's first championship long shot
rimmed out waiters got it
now father we can't wait to give back
their parade on Biscayne Boulevard
delivering the finest performance for
the ages this is your first act ended a
new plot was beginning to emerge
[Music]
act or your story brought change to be
here would be way to be here will see be
understand now that I've made the right
decision
[Applause]
as new characters were introduced to
your narrative identities were altered
it forced through fire
hammer and
pressure like that couldn't have
hindered you but instead in hard
[Music]
fortifying you as a player a man and a
leader then you reach the top of the
mountain twice more different castes
same conclusion
[Applause]
your second act saw your arrival as one
of the most respected athletes on earth
and your departure from the home to
helped you get there Dwyane Wade is back
well it's a dream come true for Heat
fans my eyes and the heart was always
here I'll say that from the beginning
you know who I am in the core and deep
down inside as always here act 3 of your
story began just over a year ago as it
was destined fate brought you back to
the city of Miami and you were welcomed
with open arms and full hearts they've
got a great way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we cheered we cried we chanted your name
all throughout the city and up to the
rafters it was more than a reunion it
was a revival of the part you were meant
to play from flash to father crime
there's something about Dwayne Wade when
you put that mine he Jersey on and play
in front of these fans and now as you
take the stage one final time we
celebrate you as the reason an entire
generation of South Floridians fell in
love with the game
[Music]
as the force that raised our spirits
higher than Ben has ever could as a
player that fell down seven times I
stood at eight because no matter what
new narratives lie ahead know that this
city will always be proud to represents
just as you carry this on yours
[Applause]
because this is and forever will be
Wade Callie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
you